aujourd'hui je vous parlais d'un nouveau
smartphone j'ai reçu deux jours cette
grosse boîte du one + 7 pro aujourd'hui
j'en suis à la fin janvier quelques
jours celle du wan plus c'est donc deux
smartphones de voix de plus cette année
il ya celui là déjà parlé il ya quelques
jours qu'il y en a qui est beau et chaud
et celui là on va en parler aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu
exceptionnel sais pas si vous voyez il
ya un peu le bazar en fait y'a tout que
je vous montre pas c'est que en fait là
sur le côté j'ai une fenêtre qui hélas
ces deux bonjour ça va zone 2 et et de
deux il est venu pour poser les fenêtres
parce que voilà il y avait les beaux
culs ford
il est venu poser les fêtes parce que
ici entier des vieilles fenêtres pas du
tout à sonoriser c'est un peu compliqué
pour la lumière et je respecte des
normes gross n'a donc ça va être cool on
fait les travaux parce qu'il faut bien
amélioré un petit peu le studio ça vous
l'aurez compris c'est un peu le bazar
donc aujourd'hui on va commencer la
vidéo comme ça mais je pense que j'étais
s'est terminé ton taf
voilà fini ses beaux-frères des déplacés
je vous montre un homme que je vous
montre jamais d'habitude cet angle là
avec la fenêtre l éclairage on est pas
mal ça pas mal merci de 2,2 rien n'est
pas ses pouvoirs ses skis ou celles à la
différence de son bon écoutez cool en
tout cas de deux c'est un pote si ça
vous intéresse je vous mets un lien
menant 10 cartons pour les voir il fait
du super boulot pour voir naître
cool si vous pensez que le one + 7 s'est
jamais rien de plus qu en moins de +6 tu
es un peu revisitée et bien vous vous
trompez sur une puce est à beaucoup
davantage à des points vraiment
d'amélioration même si je reconnais le
psychique on tiendrait voir là dessus il
ressemble trait pour trait au moins pu
assister le monde + 7 et meilleur niveau
performances il va beaucoup plus vite il
est beaucoup plus rapide
il est bien meilleur pour le multimédia
et notamment grâce haut-parleurs stéréo
c'est vraiment vraiment gros points
d'amélioration par rapport au moins de
plus 6 t de l'année dernière il ya un
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui est
vraiment beaucoup plus rapide que ce
qu'on avait 126 t il est aussi meilleur
du point de vue de l'appareil photo le
one + 7 ne ressemble pas juste owen pu
assister le one + 7 est une vraie belle
amélioration par rapport aux autres
pistes et il se situe entre le one + 6 t
et le one + 7 pro ce qui compliquait
cette année c'est que one piece la
sortie 1 où elle plus cette pro qui
vraiment au top au niveau de l'écran au
niveau de tout plein de choses
vous avez un taux de rafraîchissement de
90 m on a un écran quad hd on a un truc
vraiment complètement dingue ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que les performances
que vous allez avoir entre d'un côté le
voyait plus à de la côte est le one
piece est pro eh bien c'est exactement
la même chose snapdragon 855 6 ou 8 giga
drame alors sur le one piece est ya pas
de 12 giga de ram mais dans l'absolu
vous n'allez pas forcément besoin il
même si vous pensiez acheter en plus
cette pro vous n'avez pas forcément
acheter le modèle en 12 giga de ram donc
si j'ai bien drabo du giga de ram ça ira
déjà parfaitement bien en plus vous avez
68 kg de stockage soit 256 go de
stockage onu fs 3.0 ça vous permet
notamment d'avoir une écriture et une
lecture plus rapide que ce que vous
pouviez retrouver avant sur le web + 6 p
on l'a donc un smartphone je dirai pas
qui n'a rien à envier ou en plus cette
pro parce que c'est pas le même produit
on va pas pouvoir aller aussi loin que
roanne plus cette pro par contre le
comparer où on peut citer si ce n'est
d'un point de vue esthétique
sinon il est quand même relativement
différent
vous avez la même en cochant vous avez
le même form factor vous avez un design
qui est vraiment similaire vous
retrouver ici vos boutons sur le côté
pour venir mettre le mode sonnerie
vibreur ou alors carrément désactivé le
bouton pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre
votre recharge en usb type c vous avez
toujours votre bouton de volume ici vous
avez vraiment deux smartphones qui se
ressemblent énormément et qui pourtant
sont vraiment différentes en inde ou en
verre qui prend quand même pas mal les
traces de doigts et ça c'est toujours un
point de regret alors c'est un point de
regret mais de notre côté ce que je vous
conseille vraiment c'est de venir le
protéger avec le one piece est il est
complètement possible d'avoir des coqs
qui nous sont proposés pas où est plus
elles sont là dedans
vous avez donc la possibilité d'avoir
plusieurs coques ça vous fait un
smartphone avec la jolie petit coq rouge
ça c'est pas mal c'est vraiment sympa
vous pouvez aussi avoir cette petite
coque noire avec le relief c'est la même
que j'utilise moi sur mon one + 7 pro
vous l'apprenez tac tac tac tac vous la
mettez c'est aussi très sympa
s'intègrent bien c'est très joli ou
sinon vous avez une coque grise aussi
qui est très sympa hop on vient on poste
d'arrière là c'est un peu plus le
blizzard au niveau de l'appareil photo
je suis un peu moins fun d'aller pas son
nom c'est fabriqué ou sinon vous avez
les coques de mon partenaire rhinochill
soit la coque ça c'est pour le moins de
plus ce système et leur font aussi pour
28,7 soit le petit écrin ce gars que
vous mettez au tour et ça c'est aussi
pas mal du tout comme normalement on est
sur le même format à être le one piece
système monopuce être malin ça marche
parfaitement
d'ailleurs si elle vous intéresse je
vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description moi j'aime beaucoup le soin
qui a porté au packaging chioini plus
quand vous l'ouvrez briser toute la
partie on vous l'indiquait charger vous
levez paf le chargeur la façon dont
c'est fait j'adore il ya un énorme
boulot qui est fait au niveau du
marketing là dessus et ont tout savoir
si vous l'achetez comme ça vous avez ici
si vous le souhaitez quand même une
coque transparente qui va venir le
protéger a minima alors c'est pas la
plus belle coque par contre on vous le
voyez ça me protège sellal a le mérite
d'exister
on a donc un smartphone hyper performant
avec le stand ragon 855 je vous lis ça
marche du feu de dieu ça parfaitement
bien on a vraiment tout est hyper
alignée entre nos côtés le socle process
dans le fait d'avoir 6 ou 10 gigas de
ram ça cartonne le fait d'avoir du
stockage ont dû fc 3.0 ce qui fait le
truc va parfaitement bien c'est rapide
c'est cool on a en plus de ça une grosse
batterie de trois mille sept cent
millions terreur qui vous permet de
garder votre smartphone
à 2 jours d'autonomie ça c'est vraiment
cool et en plus ce qui est vraiment bien
si vous avez de la rocha extrêmement
rapide fait part one place ça vous
permet de le recharger en une heure en
gros vous la dire charger à 100% comme
vous allez à partir de zéro vous allez
partir de 10 à 15% vous le branchez en
une heure il est plein en une demi-heure
vous l'avez mis je sais plus combien de
charge mais c'est énorme c'est
extrêmement rapide en gros vous vous
levez le matin je mens j'ai oublié de
changer mon smartphone ce qui est
souvent mon cas et depuis d'ailleurs que
j'utilise notamment loin de plus c'est
trop je me pose plus trop la question de
la charge soit au maintien je les imans
plus batterie claque je le branche de
charges prend une douche de ressort qu
ayant des quasiment chargé c'est un truc
est vraiment énorme ça très très très
vite
et du coup on se pose plus la question
de la charge entre en termes d' usage
qui vous voulez on n'a plus à se
stresser sabathia fond je branche cette
nuit demain matin il sera prêt non quel
que soit le moment où vous avez besoin
de le brancher vous pouvez le branché il
va se rapprocher très rapidement vous
trouvez une prise vous lui mettez dix
minutes de charge dans un café le temps
de boire un coup d'attendre un train de
france que vous et ça va vite c'est
pratique c'est bien parce qu'ils
mettront alors dans métro il n'y a pas
de prise électrique
mais si vous en trouvez une seule en
cause alors certes on va pas voir les
mêmes prétentions sera bonne plus cette
pro avec un écran 3d hd mais là vous
avez quand même un écran full hd + avec
une révolution de 2340 par 1080 pixels
ratio 19 points 5/9 écran de 6,41 pouces
amoled qui est vraiment bien
d'excellente qualité et surtout
extrêmement lumineux il est vraiment
vraiment vraiment cool alors le truc
qu'on pourrait lui reprocher mais de
notre côté on est mi 2010 9 c'est le
fait d'avoir cette petite encoche ici
les encoches vont disparaître je vous
dis en 2020 les encoches on les aura
uniquement sur les modèles d'entrée de
gamme ça flirte avec le milieu de gamme
mais elles vont tout disparaître au
profit soit système pop up soit
carrément de caméras cachées sous
l'écran donc ça c'est un peu la fin des
encoches et je dirais c'est un peut-être
le dernier modèle du cac et une encoche
même sûr qu'avec le one + 71 pas le one
+ 7 protée parce que là dessus il y aura
pas de mode lte et durant one + 7 promet
il y aura pas de wall e + 7 pro t on
aura bien un point de plus cet été
celui-ci je suis quasiment sûr que l'on
koshla aura disparu je prends le pari on
va passer ensemble à la fin de l'année
mais je suis sûr que l'on coche aura
disparu qu'on aura un seul nenê grand
écran et pourquoi pas qu'une caméra
poupette ça pour avoir un sens voir ce
que nous proposera ou un de plus dans
cette version améliorée du modèle le 7 t
en tout cas tout de suite pour regarder
vos vidéos
c'est vraiment bien pour
des jeux c'est vachement mal d'ailleurs
pour jouer à des jeux vous avez un mode
qui est vraiment vraiment vraiment
génial c'est le fnatic mode vous y
retrouver dans utilitaire dans le mode
en jeu là vous pouvez tous venir régler
et là vous avez mode fina tic
lorsque vous avez dansé une partie ça
devient vraiment optimisé vous allez
pouvoir répondre aux appels via l'eau
par le rangement ça va optimiser votre
bécane ça tout optimisé c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment génial là on serine
partie joe d'aller voir le son est
vraiment vraiment vraiment énorme c'est
juste hallucinant la puissance qu'on a
derrière ça me fait parler vachement
vachement vachement encore c'est juste
hallucinant
le son vous avez sur ce smartphone c'est
ou le fait d'avoir les haut parleurs
stéréo c'est vraiment génial
le fnatic mode hélas à venir optimisé
complètement voter je ne suis pas du
tout concentré quand jouffroy en même
temps comme ça et mes mots regardant des
vidéos paf vous pouvez faire un petit
zoom alors vous avez cette petite
encoche suis d'accord mais par contre ce
qui est génial c'est lo jo c'est
absolument hallucinant leçons vous avez
l'immersion vous avez deux faces pour
moi c'est la même chose que sur le voile
+7 front vous avez un truc qui est
vraiment vraiment vraiment génial volou
kiêu fait rien quand ça le dessinateur
est oui alors j'en conviens parfaitement
et je suis d'accord et effectivement pas
de priziac là dessus donc si vous vous
dites bokassa brancher mon petit casque
je m'écoutais my music mais jeu
tranquillement si vous avez un casse
avec une prise jack
c'est strictement impossible il nous
faudra un casque bluetooth pour vous
connecter mais par contre c'est vrai que
si vous êtes par exemple si vous voulez
vous regardez un film ya plein de
smartphones
la qualité audio si vous n'avez pas de
casque c'est pas ça avec ce smartphone
c'est hallucinant la sensation
d'immersion est là surtout le spectre
vous avez pas un spectre qui a ses
tricks et très médium alors on n'est pas
des sur des haut-parleurs qui vont
développer une spectre extrêmement large
mais on a quand même un truc assez
précis on reconnaît un spectre aiguë
beaucoup dans le médium bien évidemment
médium grave on n'a pas de de bath qui
vont rhône et fatalement on n'a pas de
quoi développer un son très très très
grave mais le boulot est vraiment bien
fait le contrat est rempli la tipp à
roanne plus pour la partie je vous dis
multimédia gaming expérience de jeu avec
le fnatic mode visionnage c'est vraiment
bien le seul petit point un peu négatif
cette petite encoche tout quand on est
habitué
un modèle comme ça quand on a des tués
ou en plus cette pro et qu'on tombe
voyez où on n'a pas du tout dans koch
d'ailleurs je vous invite à les
visionner montait si ce n'est pas déjà
fait quand on a un très très grand écran
comme ça et qu'on arrête avec une petite
encoche bon à côté de ça vous n'allez
pas forcément à voir le one + 7 pro
vous allez vouloir acheter les graines
+7 sinon ce moment là c'est que tout ce
que je ne comprends plus trop mais c'est
vrai que je trouve vraiment top
si votre idée avoue c'est d'avoir un
smartphone pour visionner des vidéos
pour aller jouer à des jeux pour avoir
de la puissance quand vous appuyez sur
un bouton vous voulez que ça s'allume
pour le faire du multitâche voulez pas
vous prendre la tête voulait pas un
smartphone qui rament vous voulez pas un
truc qui vous tire un pas en arrière
avec ça franchement vous êtes tranquille
ça c'est un beau flagship killer mais là
où a depuis continué un petit peu de
mettre la barre encore plus haut c'est
au niveau de l'appareil photo parce
qu'il vous intègre à l'intérieur de
caméras la première caméra c'est une
carabine caméra de 48 mégapixels
j'en ai déjà parlé c'est le capteur sony
mx 5 186 l'ordre et faire des photos en
faible luminosité va vous prendre qu'à
pixels vous faire un seul même les gros
pixels et ça vous permettra
effectivement sortir une photo de 12
mégapixels qui sera vraiment bien et
l'adapter en plus de ça derrière ils
vous opposez des jolies petites
lentilles ce pack vous le verrez pas
comme ça en gros vous ont mis cette
lentille boutabout ça vous permet
d'avoir une optique est vraiment bien
qui ouvre à f
1.7 qui est en tout cas je trouve
excellente et qui fait un très bon
boulot
il ya un beau travail logiciels qui a
été fait c'est vrai qu'au début j'ai vu
beaucoup de retours négatifs sur le wan
+7 proulx qui a aussi une caméra 48
mégapixels qui venait du problème
logiciel
je sais que certains médias l'ont
rencontré moi je n'ai pas du tout
rencontrer dès que j'ai eu besoin de
plus cette proche et pourtant la même
version logicielle j'ai absolument eu
aucun problème j'ai continué avec ce one
+ 7 g c'est bien évidemment la mise à
jour et j'ai absolument non plus aucun
problème donc faut que les photos sont
bien un très bon rendu j'ai voulu
montrer dans quelques instants
et vous avez une deuxième caméra c'est
une caméra de 5 mégapixels qui est là en
renfort qui ouvre à f 2.4 qui est là
pour le mode portrait pour les faits
évoqués pour le flou d'arrière plan
les deux faux fait l'ensemble ça va bien
vous n'avez pas de grand angle vous avez
pas avoir un téléobjectif
mais le boulot qui fait avec ça est
vraiment bien maîtrisé et à l'avant dans
la petite encoche ici vous avez une
caméra de 16 mégapixels qui ouvre à
2.103 commencer par la photo de nuit qui
a pour changer ça c'est une photo que
j'ai prise dans le studio toutes
lumières éteintes
je dis bien toutes lumières éteintes
vous n'avez absolument aucun éclairage
j'ai par contre poser la caméra sur un
petit trépied si nous permet d'avoir un
truc où on a vraiment une netteté qui
est quand même assez incroyable pour le
boulot qu'elle fait là dessus deux
jeunes photo pareil avec le pied c'est
exactement la même chose c'est assez ouf
et par contre j'ai fait une photo où
j'ai tenu à la main et là tout de suite
c'était tout de suite beaucoup moins
terrible l'emmener sur les photos qui
est prise avec la caméra de celle ci
j'aime beaucoup l'histoire que le
travail est bien fait alors j'ai
vraiment une tête de pont croix là
dessus vous me pardonnerez pour le
pingouin mais j'ai pas d'autre mot
d'ailleurs si vous trouvez un mot plus
sympathique pour le mettre en
commentaire ça me dérange absolument pas
mais le rendu aussi cool pour les selphy
ça marche bien c'est vraiment sympa vous
avez ensuite chiffres des photos qui
sont prises avec le capteur principal on
est dans les conditions de bonne
luminosité il ya de la lumière c'est
bien gardé vous avez quand même
vachement de détails je trouve que les
couleurs sont bien respectées il ya un
beau boulot qui fait de la part de one
plus haut niveau du traitement logiciel
la caméra avec le capteur 48 mégapixels
à sonia mx 5 186 marche parfaitement
bien regarder ça là les détails que vous
avez sur la fleur mémoire nous joue mais
comme ça c'est top je trouve que
vraiment pour faire des photos à voir
des superbes souvenirs des photos à
garder là dessus il ya un vrai beau
boulot qui est fait de la part de one
pluzz ça c'est top pareil plein soleil
en un côté un peu plus en bras j'ai une
partie cap plus ensoleillés n'est pas du
tout brûler lappartient qu'il faille un
peu plus ombragé on devine bien on voit
bien le veinage des feuilles enfin pour
moi ya un vrai beau travail logiciel
dolby à puce nfc double carte sim
bluetooth 5.0 enfin vous avez vraiment
un smartphone qui est très complet qui
est vraiment très bien fabriquer de la
part de wyplosz avec de belles finitions
un smartphone que je trouve vraiment
comme je ne sais pas comment vous le
trouvez vous qu'est ce que vous en
pensez il vous plait ce one + 7 et j'ai
une question un peu plus compliqué est
ce que vous pensez que le moigne +7 va
marcher avec en face le one + 7 pro vous
par exemple si vous deviez choisir ou si
vous avez fait votre choix
vous partiriez vous vous êtes parti sur
lequel on peut set où elle fut sept pros
sur le wan +7 on commence avec la
version 16 giga de ram à 709 euros et
après les tarifs 27 ans 59 et tutti
quanti
tandis que sur le wan plus est on
commence à 559 euros pour la version 6
giga de ram 128 go de stockage et 8
gigas de ram 256 go de stockage
on est à 609 euros on a quand même un
écart significatif de prix entre les
deux produits
normal à notre côté on a quand même des
produits qui sont quand même
relativement différent awan plus c'est
pour qu'il fera plus de choses celui là
qui en fera un peu moins mais qui est
vraiment bien par contre en terme de
puissance pour moi c'est la même chose
hormis la version 12 giga de ram mais
bon c'est pas forcément l'utiliser à
fond pour les ai cité 12
vraiment qu'est ce que vous en pensez
quel est pour vous le meilleur produit
ceci étant dit on a deux beaux modèles
de one + moi je trouve que moins de +7
est vraiment bien a vous de me dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
et si vous intéresse vous avez un petit
lien pour aller acheter sur le silo à ne
plus vous allez voir vous m'en direz des
nouvelles
sur ce je vous embrasse vous dis à
demain soyez sages ciao